this is the bismillah al hamdulillah
Salaam alaikum peace be with you and you
are watching the Dean show today in the
den show studio back with us sheikh
ibrahim sedan tests and trials of life
how to handle it one minute everything's
good the next minute it's a calamity
where do you go who do you run to for
help why is it happening do you win do
you take it like a man what do you do
all these questions answered it more on
this week's show sit tight we'll be
right back this is the days the danger
this is the this is the this is the
Salam alaikum peace me out to you Shane
how are you how are you thank you for
finding a time to be with us again it's
my please we are going to get right into
the top because the time is short we
always love when we have you in the
studio and the topic today that we're
going to cover people tune in every week
for some knowledge of this Dean the
fastest-growing Dean fast is one way of
life in the world Islam way of life of
all the prophets isn't it a total
complete submission to the one who
created us and in his book the Quran has
he sat down preserved no additions
deletions it's there and it's original
we have all the answers to our problems
and now one of the key problems a lot of
people are facing is the calamities
every day it's a testing trial so is
this part of the test that Allah the
Creator is talking about that we're
going to be tested and how do people
deal with these tests when they come one
day everything is good the next day
you're crying you're balling it is a lot
mad at us is a long one and make things
difficult for us how do we handle this
sum let Hamilton else office that I
wanna sort of that a lot that most time
had made the human being in such a way
that is different than the rest of the
creation of Allah we have means of
intellect that we can look beyond the
physical things that we're in we can
think and we can analyze and we can do
things for what's coming ahead and this
is by itself is such a unique for the
human being and as a result of that
almost panel Tejada prepared us for
facing tests and trials for what reason
not just to be tested but for the human
being to worship none but the creator of
their engineers meaning acts of worship
are so many one of which patients
devotion the ancients they don't have
this the human being a las panel to
Allah created them so that they would do
certain acts of worship that none of the
creation of Allah will be able to
achieve one of which is patience
struggle for the sake of Allah since
he's the most wise and one of which that
we have to go through tests on the face
of it if not we will be faced with a
test at the moment of death after death
in the graves there would be questions
this is test that we have to prepare
ourselves for and it's not good to be
intoxicated and to live in ignorance and
forgetfulness because one day or the
other something has to face the human
being this is the nature of life for
what purpose so that when we are faced
with tests and calamities we know
exactly what to do that a las panel
Tyler wants from us to be patient to be
pleased with the destiny of the most
twice he's the most twice anything
happens happens for a reason and the
most noble reason it is what a las panel
data says in the Quran wanna holla
provisional inside Lydia who do that I
did not create the human beings or did
though the journey except to worship me
to establish this meaning this broad
meaning of worship times of ease times
of difficulties times of adversity times
of goodness anything the person is being
a servant of almost ran over so we say
Allah were talking with the creator of
the heavens and earth the crater the
moon and the Sun and everything in this
universe the one God and this one God
this one creator so he created us and
we're being tested is every second of
our life everything is being recorded
right and this is either pass or fail if
you pass you got paradise if you fail
the Hellfire right and it's the mercy of
Allah that would not left alone like
some people think that books have been
brought down that messengers have been
sent so that they would teach the people
what they won't know just by what they
see around them the human beings have no
capacity to get to know what Allah wants
from them unless they would follow the
messengers of Allah and Allah Spanish
Allah says in the quran and i'll send us
already
but yet when Zell navara won't get
airborne Mizell the equipment naturalist
which means that we had sent messengers
our messengers with clear signs and
arguments and evidence with the book and
the balance of what is right and what is
wrong for what purpose so that people
will do with it what is just to know
what is just and what is not just we
need the messengers of Allah the final
message is the message of prophet
muhammad sallallahu ala the final book
is the Quran that teaches us how to be
just just with ourselves when something
bad happens to a person how to deal with
oneself how to deal with others and to
endure patients and to be pleased with
whatever happens seek andheri words from
a most panel data that he's the most
twice and there many incidences and many
things in the Quran and in the way of
the prophets allah island that would
teach the believers how to act at times
of calamity can you before we cut to a
break can you give us the commentary on
a verse which the meaning of is that
Allah the Creator is saying that I have
not created life and death except to
test which of you are best in action
what is this I mean this is in salat al
Maliki los panel taluses tabarak la dee
da dee el mundo ala kulli shayin kadir
and that if Alec and Mel tower theatre
lee avenue akuma akuma cinema that he's
the creator of the heavens and the earth
and the creator of the heavens and the
earth he is the most twice he does not
do things out of no meaning to it and
then he said they'll have the lower come
the one that created life and death for
what purpose to test you who among you
will be the best of the doers of good
deeds doer of good deeds with a good
actions right righteous best among and
that's why I life and it is this so our
whole life mission is to be in a
constant can you say a state of
self-development to develop yourself to
be the best human being possible and
that's why amen or faith is not just a
belief in the heart and a person can do
whatever they want and live their life
the way that they like and desire no
every day is a day where we elevate
ourselves a man or faith is made of so
many parts as the Prophet
Eliza let me said 70 something were 60
something parts the highest of it is to
believe in Maryland no one is worthy of
worship except Allah the most high and
the lowest level of e men is to remove
an obstacle from the path this is by
itself is part of our faith so in
between there are so many levels that's
why every day with elevate ourselves
that's why for those who and all of us
we would face one way the other some
tests and some difficulties with the
faith and with this belief and this
attitude a person is able to be the
strongest when it comes to facing these
types of community say let's take a
break when we come back for more right
back for more and sheikh ibrahim sedan
here on the Dean shop so tight he is
little born about 60 years ago in former
Yugoslavia today's Bosnia at the Second
World War imagine today you have one
child ill so much it's important that we
realize that Islam is a gift so we
believe that in the teachings of Jesus
what is left there is truth in the clean
he's the Wiz but the truth has been
mixed up with paganism and with nature
worship and so Islam has given you a
pure straightforward way of approaching
monotheism
back on the Dean show with sheikh
ibrahim sedan in the Dean show studio
and we're talking about the test of life
so life is one big test and we're being
tested so we want to pass now let's talk
a little bit about the wisdom of this
test I mean it's kind of easy like you
know without the calamity sometimes
somebody will say yeah I believed is
that and then some hits and then that
person just you know he jumped ship so
can you comment you commented on one
verse from the noble Qur'an the glorious
quran the verbatim word of god now let's
go to another one i believe is in
chapter 29 the second verse or God
Almighty the crater Allah is saying s
ibanez a yahoo he's yes can you comment
in English he's saying that you know do
you think that you're going to be left
alone just saying that you believe and
you're not going to be tested can talk
about this test and lost panel Tyler
after this verse he said that we have
tested the people before you so that the
truthful ones would be shown distinctly
from those who are not truthful ones so
this is the purpose of the test people
are times of ease everybody can be good
but the real people the truthfulness of
the people shows at times of adversities
and difficulties you would know a friend
not when you're enjoying your life and
everybody is healthy and everybody's
wealthy and everything you won't know
your friend very well till you are a
neat that something happens to you those
who are close to you those who are
truthfully they wants to be friends of
yours not because they want something
from you so this is a fact of life that
the real mannerism and the real
characteristics of a human being shows
clearly when it's time of difficulties
so that's why I lost final tada the most
wise I would like to comment on
something very important many people
they would say why would a las hyerollah
create this big test and what's the
purpose of all of the sea can just take
everybody to agenda and the matter is
over paradise right the purpose of this
there are so many reasons of course but
one of the great meanings that many
people are not aware of we know that God
has names and attributes the perfect
names and attributes one of which that
he
is the most forgiving that he is a sub
or the one that is for bearing
forbearance and his patient and so on
these qualities and attributes are to a
lot regard even if there is nothing to
practically to prove this but because of
the creation of the human beings where
this attribute will be in place if
there's no human beings if there's no
test on the face of it there has to be
sins to be forgiven there has to be some
difficulties for people to endure
patients and to seek reward from Allah
to turn to Him alone human beings are
tend to be ignorant they don't turn to
the creator of the heavens and the earth
only unless they are in time of distress
most of them like this but God wants
from us that at times of ease we turned
to him and at times of difficulties we
turned to him I remember one time I was
in a plane this was like maybe 15 years
ago the plane was over the ocean and the
pilot said like this like we're not sure
if the gas will take us all the way to
the States will try to land somewhere
north because of the resistance of the
air but were not sure he said this
people were before that having fun
drinking you know things like that once
he said that I watched people in the
plane everybody looked up they know in
their heart that a las panel that is the
most high at this time it cannot be
explained with words I can say it and
were relaxed like this but when a person
faces a moment like this the really
e-man and faith comes in place and this
is mentioned in the Quran had a the
horrible feel full there are hola
magazine and LD when the disbelievers
are in the ocean on a ship and now the
the storm comes in place they would turn
to Allah sincerely they're not thinking
about the means in this life anymore a
test comes see the benefit of it that
they would turn their hearts will be
completely in this state of worship
turning to the creator of the heavens
and yours alone asking for help from him
when all the wordly means won't benefit
them this is such a noble act of worship
that we want to be in that state when we
are at times of ease now for example
were not in the calendar
you know but where is this attachment of
our hearts to the creator of the heavens
the news that we are really feel that we
are in need of him like someone drowning
and he's holding to a piece of wood in
the middle of the ocean how his do I and
supplication how sincere it is is not
thinking about the ship and the plane
coming he's sincerely turning to the
Creator alone saying Oh God helped me
this sincerity you need to develop at
times of ease not just the times of
difficulties and this is what a lot of
the most high ones from us to be true
servants of the creator of the heavens
and the earth not to turn to no one but
him now we'll see that you know trying
to look for the wisdoms and things and
some of these tests are the test when
you go through these trials if you pass
them with patience if you're for bearing
does this increase your email your your
favors you're supposed to make you a
stronger believer of course and this is
one of the great benefits also that it
changes the human being make him a
better human being lost panel data says
in the Quran what I never were not going
to show you how if he were journey or
not so minimal diverse that we will test
you buy something this is the mercy of
Allah not all fear but some fees and
some hunger and some loss of wealth and
loss of life right so and then he says
we're very sorry and give glad tidings
to those who are patient patient is a
key word here right but then the verse
after it explains what are those patient
ones those when a calamity afflicted
this is what the verse says they would
say in arid Lahey were in naval hero
zero which means they say that with the
Tungus but their hearts is full of that
belief conviction that we belong to
Allah we are owned by Allah and we shall
return to him if the tongue would say
this and the heart believes in this no
matter how heavy the calamity is it
brings so much tranquility and peace in
one's life we are owned by Allah and we
shall return to him so what really
matters is how our return to him and
he's the most wise he's all watching us
so we need to have the good expectations
that nothing happens from
unless its were great wisdom for us
maybe a person has been away from Allah
and he did not come back to him at times
of ease calamity hits it's not something
that is good for the human being but
what good comes after this is that the
person would flee to a lost fan of that
and have the love of a lost panel data
in one's heart and tend to instance it I
don't know if you can recollect but from
your own personal experience I know
people that when the times of trial come
either at that time or later they start
to reflect and ask the crater to let
them know the wisdom behind it they
might not see it at that moment maybe
you can share some stories or something
and comment on this but later they saw
from this test there there was something
that they perceived as bad but then
later so much good blossom from it can
you comment on this this is a very
important point because we do not know
what is good for us and in many cases
some for example even some worldly
things a person wanted to go to medical
school so bad right and he would think
that if i don't go to medical school
this is there i'm gonna be a loser in my
life and he applied and applied then he
never get accepted and he would feel so
much misery how can these other people
can be accepted or not me why me not and
things like this but then coming after
10 years or 20 years when he sees that
his status is so much better and that he
lost planet allah guided him and
directed him in a certain path that he
feel that this is the best thing for him
he would look back and he see i was
silly to be said of something that i'm
not sure exactly if it's good for me or
not same thing when it comes to
marriages the same thing that when it
comes to any relationship we need to
reflect and see the wisdom of Allah why
this has happened see the life of the
human beings is so complex person coming
from another part of the world to meet
someone and then all of a sudden they
get married and see how the effect of
such a relationship that we need to
reflect on the wisdom of Allah spano
Tala that it all has to come into the
meaning of establishing the worship of
Allah spinodal on the face of it and
this is something that a Lost Planet
Allah ordered us to reflect on and two
see and when we see that in every day of
our life we would see that there's
amazing work of the creator of heavens
in you we're going to take another break
and we'll be right back with more God
will inshallah sit tight no problem you
can take my daughter to dinner you and
my daughter and me anything do you ever
tell you something it's natural guess
the idea God created it and he created
us to have a good time you should have a
good time one without wives though Islam
is the fastest growing religion in the
world and most of the converts are women
not men they see that the rules of Islam
instead of constraining it the rule set
them free the one we take this from home
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if allies by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone if allies by
my side I am Not Afraid
I am not afraid to stand alone if Eliza
I am not afraid to step back here on the
Dean show we're talking about the test
the test of life and we're expounding on
some of the verses from the glorious
quran the verbatim word of God and given
us some commentary and some advice now
should somebody who's going through this
test you mentioned the person that was
excited about medical school didn't get
accepted and then later he sees after
year ten years two months whatever the
case he sees that wow this was silly
that I was upset over this is the state
of this person is it going to evolve to
something better if he's patient rather
than let's say he doesn't get accepted
and he turns his back on the crater he
turns his back on prayer he turns his
back on doing good and he just you know
lets loose or he's said fast is it
normal he's a little bit depressed but
still in his heart he holds on he knows
that you know what my craters never
going to let me down and we'll keep
doing what I was supposed to be doing
worshiping him alone establishing the
prayer being good doing good and then by
doing this well then he'll see the
blossom the fruit of his hard work and
patience right that's definitely
patients would never leave the person to
any form of loss never the best life
that a person would live is the life of
being patient by witnessing the wisdom
of a loss paneled either that nothing
happens without the perfect wisdom of a
la spinetta he wants you to be a true
servants to him so as a result of that
anything that happens to us we feel
honored that a lot of the most high had
in his knowledge that we have to be
afflicted by this oh that for us to turn
to him alone so with patience and
there's a very beautiful hadith of the
prophet saw something that shows how to
develop this patient in our life he said
a sober and the supplemented Allah which
means patience is in the first instant
not that we wait for years afterwards
and we say
to let that this was my path no you're
hit by a calamity in the same instant
you are witnessing the wisdom of the
creator you see this is his destiny and
I'm willing to be pleased with it and I
know that it will bring good to me with
the condition that I'm patient and
seeking the pleasure of the creator of
the heavens in the earth I don't and
that's why if we want to be patient and
we want to have our forms of happiness
from calamities happen and it will
happen we have to die a person gets a
you know something has to happen for us
to reach this level we need to develop
this one we are at times of ease you
know when a person is hit by calamity
what most people do they get trapped
into this moment of calamity they forget
that they lived in so much long time in
matters of ease and goodness so while
the times of ease we need to develop the
II Men and the faith and turn to Allah
alone that's why the five daily prayers
reminders of this so that anything
happens we are connected constantly so
we would see that and that's why the
most happiest people in the face of
earth at the people of early man the
believers and not the ones that are
intoxicated inside a few more points
before we run out of time so we
mentioned that so this is for the person
who stays patient but if you flip out
and you do opposite are you just
bringing more harm to yourself you're
pressing yourself and you know you be
the the means to your own destruction
right because the calamity is like a
message I let it coming to you from the
king you're supposed to behave in such a
way because of this either a person will
behave accordingly or he is heedless of
it he's heedless of it then that means
he is in danger so that's why we need to
witness the wisdom of Allah something
happens that we should ask themself
there's something here meant for me to
do that God wants something for me to do
he wants me to do something how can we
know this it's not by dreams or anything
it's what's in the revelation Quran and
so no the prophets are seldom and what
is meant for us is to turn to Him alone
and to worship Him and to make
remembrance to him and to deal with
others with goodness Allah says Magyar
Nevada Calabar bean fitness and auto
Sweden we made you to one another
calamity and a test
I am a test to you and your intestine if
you are in any relationship people are
test to one another so what to do he
said ah taas virile should you then be
patient I should be patient dealing with
you you patient dealing with me knowing
what Allah wants from you dealing with
me a husband with his wife my husband
with his children the same thing the
wife with her husband and the children
what I lost panel Tyler wants from us in
these types of relationship because it's
all tests because a lot of moves twice
we do not meet people just like that
without a meaning or a reason for it no
it's meant that you meet that person in
that particular place that you marry
that person and so on and so forth
everything in our life is with the great
wisdom of Allah soprano Donna and his
knowledge in his mercy and we end with
the last point where you mentioned shake
that at the moment patience is at the
moment you lose a loved one someone who
is so dear to your heart now is time for
patience your wife she spills some some
you know she ruins your favorite outfit
you come home and you freaking up
patients at that moment husband gets a
second what patients it's okay so
whatever we just I'm giving examples
that's all so something happens you
think of the worst at that time right
then is to you know you want to let out
you want to just vamp you want to just
scream and you want to break something
you don't want to do that right is that
correct run just patience and patience
meaning a debt movement me remembrance
of allah say in 1999 a yellow jewel
don't say that F word don't say a curse
word don't punch somebody they'd say it
hmmm didn't then allah is the most twice
there's something mentees yeah right and
it doesn't mean that we become too bad
things or relax the truth no we do the
right thing but we need to have this we
say our all mm innocent analogy we seek
refuge in Allah from the devil and so on
but we have to to train ourselves at
times of ease when this is coming I'm
ready for any test can you put your head
on the ground make surgery prostration
also fall down put your head down right
so dude if a person is something good
happen and he makes the jewel to be
grateful to Allah spent on it but
something close to this is to rush to
the silent rush and make two units of
Prayer that's right you can do it's
unsettling whatever something concerned
in he would rush to
mckean will do makes anal of equivalent
standings I'll and get it all out yeah
cry complain to the Creator you do yeah
you make all the dryer and other the
right complain the good complaint is
when you can play not complaining but
you're getting all of your feelings out
to the one that is the most merciful to
you yeah he's doing that it's not
seeking pity from the people or just
come to the creator of the heavens on
earth thank you very much shake thank
you very much my god almighty the
Creator Allah reward you thank you yeah
and that was another episode of the Dean
show from the womb to the tomb and it's
one test in between so we want to pass
the test we got some great advice from
the Sheikh continue to tune in here to
the Dean show keep us in your duas and
we look forward to having you here with
us again next time here on the Dean show
until then peace be unto you
he created the universe to hang along
the heavens and the earth the everliving
he is the first he's the owner mercy
Ethan his messengers to all his
creatures on the great danger Oh
worshipping Allah then Allah there is
none greater
when the Creator